bien je ne sais pas si nous sommes dans
l'antenne
je ne sais pas si nous sommes à
l'antenne je n'en ai pas la moindre idée
mais si le design est bien je dois vous
dire que d'une part il y as pour le
début de cette année 1966 un gigantesque
embouteillage place de la concorde
il y a des coups de dés coups
d'avertisseur de pardon de fort charmant
téléspectateurs je pense qu'ils sont
autour de nous seulement je ne sais pas
alors là franchement par une seconde
vous êtes gentils ya des gens peut-être
qu'ils sont avec nous qui nous écoutent
qui nous regarde pas de même leur donner
merci on a pas j'aurais tout de même
dire que je ne sais pas du tout rejet
pierre et jean marc thibault
comment les vedettes vont pouvoir
arriver jusqu'ici parce que toutes les
avenues et toutes les rues qui donne sur
la place de la concorde sont absolument
boucher et d'autre part je vous annonce
aussi que je ne vous entends pas
voilà alors si vous voulez me dire
quelque chose essayer je suis en train
d'appuyer là avec cet appareil barbara
l'intérieur de mon oreille je ne vous
entends toujours pas sans rappeler les
bonnes soirées avec telus dans
intervilles ans admet le public est
toujours à côté
le public est toujours à côté de nous
mais je dois dire que je n'ai rien
d'autre à vous annoncer
et par conséquent ici de la concorde je
vous rend l'antenne à la maison de leur
père
ouais ça lui plaît pas